بينما يرتفع عدد الشهداء في غزه تثير
تصرفات الجنود الاسرائيليين التي وصفها
كثيرون بالمستفزة
على جدران منزلا في قطاع غزه وارسال
الصوره لها من الفيديوهات التي نشرها جنود
الاحتلال ايضا مقطع لجندي اسرائيلي يدعى
جيه هوشمان وهو يسبح في شاطئ غزه
نش
ايوه ماخفش
العز الحكومه الاسرائيليه لم تعلق على هذه
التصرفات لكن انتم كيف علقتم على هذه
المشاهد دعونا نبدا هنا بحساب
يارا اذا يارى تقول القبيح الغير مفهوم في
هالنوعيه من البشر دائما يعملوا من خراب
ديار غيرهم ومسيه سحت لاحتفالات اي نوع من
الدماء يجري في عروقهم نصل ايضا الى
امل كم عريس وعروسه من اهل غزه استشهدوا
كان باقي فرحهم ايام لكن بسبب اجرامهم
اللي مش راضي يوقفهم حرموهم من فرحتهم نصل
ايضا الى ماركو يقول ماركو اقسم بالله
جائزه الاوسكار للتمثيل السنه دي المفروض
تروح لاسرائيل
يقتلوا الاطفال يتظاهروا بانهم الابرياء
ومساكين وكانه العالم ضدهم اخيرا نصل معكم
الى علي يقول عليه تصرفات استفزازيه لا
رحمه ولا انسانيه ولا قطره خجل وتعكس عمق
الكراهيه والدمويه والرغبه بالقتل والذبح
لكل ما هو ادمي في غزه بل والشماته والفخر
بافعالهم الوحشيه لكن في حدثه اخرى اقدم
مستوطنون اسرائيليون على تعليق راس حمار
عند اقدم المقابر الاسلاميه في القدس
لنشاهد تقريبا
عن اذا بتق
[تصفيق]
ت محافظه القدس علق على الحادثه بالقول ان
احد المستوطنين قام باقتحام مقبره باب
الرحمه وعلق راس حمار على احد القبور ردت
الشرطه الاسرائيليه في بيان انها القت
القبض على مشتبه يبلغ من العمر 35 عاما من
سكان جنوبي اسرائيل في البلدات القديمه
بالقدس مدعيه انه من ذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه وتمت احالته الى التحقيق بشبهه
اساءه معامله الحيوانات وانتهاك النظام
العام